let's get more now on that news that
philip schofield has revealed he's gay
the tv presenter has been married for
nearly 27 years and says
his decision is supported by his wife
and family
earlier mr scofield appeared on the itv
show he co-hosts with holly willoughby
to explain his decision to come out
i mean i feel a little lighter yeah um
but i
also i'm very very aware of you know
that there's no question that i've
it causes pain and it causes upset um
you've
um you've been very open and honest with
steph
all the way through this yeah i have no
secrets we've never had any secrets
i've you know had to deal with this in
my head for quite some time
and so you know we've gone through this
together and we've been honest and we've
been
open um and seth
as i said you know you can't i can't
write in any statement
what i feel about that woman
well let's speak to the singer will
young who is also the author of a
forthcoming book
how to be a gay man and he joins us now
from los angeles hello to you will
and we heard in that clip there philip
schofield talking about
grappling with this for a long time he's
talked about it
consuming him consuming his head what
will it have taken
for him to come out today
well thanks for having me on um i can't
talk or someone else so i can't suppose
what is going on in another person it's
not for me to do that
um what i can rel i mean i can relate i
watched
the interview uh earlier this morning i
woke up to a
deluge of texts all praising him
which was lovely and i watched the
interview and actually got very
emotional because i thought it was
uh wonderful and beautiful and felt a
lot of pride
and empathy uh and respect huge amount
of respect
um for me uh when i came out
for myself when i was at university um
that was 2000 and then came out from the
beginning of my career which was quite
it was very rare then um i did need to
have the
uh my family and my friends and the
people i work with
supporting me and i definitely had that
and it seems like well it's obvious that
he has that as well
i think it's a day to celebrate i think
it's absolutely
wonderful yeah and it's interesting you
came out publicly in 2002
shortly after pop idol um
in the public eye and i wonder how much
has changed in the 17 18 years
since then because philip himself says
in the statement he his inner conflict
contrasts with an outside world that has
changed so very much
for the better that today being gay is a
reason to celebrate
what he's struggling with is is the hurt
that he's causing to his family as we
heard him say there
yeah i mean it's changed so much i mean
i remember during the last week of pop
idol going on to this morning
with uh phillip schofield on there
and my gosh it's changed and
it's something to celebrate it always
was something to celebrate uh
i mean what has been interesting
actually in the book
that i've done over the last year is
going back through
the media you know particularly papers
um radio and their homophobia towards
a gay pop star an openly gay pop star
which i was um
and it shows me one how horrific it was
then
uh because i was just the kind of
walking
you know moripole and an example of how
gay
men and gay people were treated at that
time um
and now it's completely different and
the things that was said uh
about me you know they'd never be said
now and i think it's just brilliant that
you have someone
on who's the anchor of one of the most
popular shows
in britain um you know being authentic
and open
and the support is overwhelming uh
and and like i said what a day to
celebrate that
that visibility because it's all about
visibility um
and the important thing you know good
point to make the important thing about
that show
is that a lot of families watch it and
it's really important for parents
to understand what it's like you know so
it educates them because what i always
say is
as adults we've come a long way in terms
of right particularly over the last 10
years
but we're still woefully letting down
our children
uh in the education system i've had
meetings with two education ministers
michael gove nicki morgan
and been hugely disappointed by their
lack of focus
and discipline on how to prevent
homophobia
in schools yeah and i suppose
well the fact that we're even talking
about this that a man comes out as gay
in 2020 should be
headline news says something doesn't it
at what point do we get to where
we're not even talking about this yeah i
think that's a really good point i guess
the thing is with sexuality that it's
something that's not sort of seen
um so it'll probably always be
a talking point and also uh you know men
liking men women liking
women is in the minority
um and that's just a fact
so it is going to be more likely
newsworthy i think what's so great is
that we're talking about it
and having an open dialogue about it in
a very positive way
in in an intelligent way um and like i
said i do
think that the focus really needs to be
on young people
you know the use of the i did a campaign
with stonewall a few years ago
about the use of the word gay the
misappropriation of the use
of the word gay is a negative uh
context which is now still used i mean
it's pretty much in the dictionary as a
gay means no stopping so gay that's so
wrong and if you're
growing up as a young gay person and you
hear constantly
it's what i say in the book you know
which is what i had constantly messages
of
being gay means it's wrong it's bad it's
defunct
then you get a huge amount of gay shame
which is the reason why
twice as many young gay people uh try to
kill themselves
you know and then you go up to
transgender people and that's almost
three times as much in comparison to
young straight people so we've got to
address it in schools
yeah and you talk in the book as well
about this
legacy of gay shame what do you mean by
that
will well gay shame is
um growing up like i just sort of
alluded to growing up in a society where
one doesn't feel the norm so i didn't
feel the norm i didn't feel
accepted uh i had you know if you
if you don't have acceptance at home or
you don't feel you can open up at home i
mean i was at boarding school which was
horrific in itself so i didn't spend so
much time at home
you don't have safety in the education
system and you don't have safety in the
wider society
even though when you get to a point my
mother messaging me
hang on a sec um even though you get to
a point
when um you come out you've still got
a historical amount of trauma and shame
in your body
and that's what leads to um abuse
uh you know of oneself that's what leads
to
addiction um so it's something that's
really underexplored and that's why i
wanted to write the book
and talk about it in my own life and how
i got through it
yeah one of the things that philip said
this morning in his interview was that
he sits on that sofa in the itv studio
day in day out and he talks to people
who are
confronting their own truths that he
asks those questions he hears them
you yourself have sat there on that sofa
and that he felt it was now the time to
be honest
with himself as well as with the public
how much did you feel that
responsibility as someone in the public
eye
to come out i didn't feel responsibility
because it was so much
it was it was if i felt responsibility
it was to myself
um and i remember people did suggest
that because at that time pop stars
didn't come out you know you just sort
of
you just sort of hide it you know and i
just thought the idea of
pretending to you know walk around with
sort of staged photographs of me with a
pretend girlfriend
would just crush me because i'd already
come out did you come under pressure to
do that well
yeah oh gosh yes i mean i had you know i
say this in the book you know
i had uh a head of the record company
saying that i sounded too gay
when i sang leave right now i had to
re-record it four times
i had the same head of the record
company suggesting that
i did a duet with george michael at the
brits and we kissed at the end to sort
of
that would be the only way that i could
get on the brits
i had me dancing with a male mannequin
in a video and someone said
you know we're worried about this and it
will it will
show the downturn of will's career i
mean it's basically homophobia
um i had people in in the
certain papers suggesting that i was
part of a a
gang at school where i homophobic abused
kids i had a radio dj uh
making fun of my sexuality saying it was
my birthday and i was going to put on
lipstick and a dress and the bbc
um i've got the copies of the
correspondence between
uh my lawyer and the bbc and the bbc
then were anything but
um kind of kind about it
um you know and the list goes on but
thankfully
this is not a sob story for me because
we're through that now and
and all through it as well i was damned
if i was going to
be anything other than true to myself
and i what i think so
brilliant and inspiring is that phillip
schofield talks about his well-being and
he puts that
you know at the key of of the
the driving force behind him wanting to
talk uh do the interview on the sofa
with holly which i thought
and was amazing got to think about our
well-being he also talks about
that public perception that you don't
know what's going on in his words
someone's seemingly perfect
life from the outside things can appear
one way
and inside very well yeah yeah and maybe
you experience it being on the camera
um you know there's no such thing as
perfect um
what i thought was brilliant is they
both spoke about how they always say to
people
talk always talk to someone and that's
what when i give well-being talks
um you know i always say you've gotta
you know you've gotta share it with
because otherwise it eats you up inside
so
a very inspirational interview and a
very inspirational program actually this
morning
will young thank you very much indeed
for talking to us here on sky news
do i look like a plumber
the hats are good it's a good look